hello everyone welcome to rational
science the only site on the internet
that does physics
we do physics right
uh everyone else does what uh
mathematics as we call it
they move concepts around
we are the only site that moves physical
objects right
that's how we do science that's how we
do physics and we're going to start uh
with one of the branches
of science which is physics and within
physics there's a
you could say a branch
specialty right
known as paleontology and within that we
have extinction so we deal with
extinction under physics okay
it's uh one of the branches out there
that involves
physicality
and that's why we deal with it the other
reason i deal with extinction just for
for your knowledge is that you know uh
relativists
mathematicians in general they believe
we're gonna live forever you know that's
what they fed hollywood and that's what
hollywood fed the masses so everybody
believes that we're gonna live forever
and that there's no problem that man
cannot fix
right and so because of that
everybody's got uh this notion that
you know uh
nothing imminent is about to happen
and so they're being blindsided as far
as i'm concerned uh to what's really
going on and what's going to be
happening very soon okay
within our lifetimes
almost guaranteed
okay so let's get started with the
extinction part and i'm going to do some
some news uh headlines that caught my
eye this week related to that
and
some of the things that are going on in
the world you know the evolution of
society evolution of our economics
evolution of our military and politics
right
okay and here's uh one of the uh things
that came up it was these uh taliban uh
as you know they took over the
government in afghanistan it's now known
as f taliban
and they uh they said yeah women can
study uh but they have to study separate
from men you know
segregation we have segregation in the
schools over there okay
and they believe that women should study
certain things that are authorized by
islam okay according to them they're
reading of
their scriptures right
and i suppose these are the subject
matters uh that they're gonna be the
girls are gonna be looking at in
college you know babysitting midwifing
cooking sewing
is that what they're gonna be studying
because uh
the article says that uh this this comes
from the taliban okay this is what they
say this is the answer they gave they
said women should give birth and raise
children
that's their job okay they should be
limited to that and nothing else okay
well i'm sure a lot of women are
struggling to get to tala to taliban
land to
kabul
please don't crowd the airplanes girls
okay
there's there's room enough for all of
you okay
uh so what i did as a result of that
when i saw that uh
you know that
the
notion that the taliban have that women
should only give birth
and raise children that's their job
that's their only function in life
i ordered a uh taliban dictionary okay
and i received it this morning this very
morning from kabul directly from kabul
and i looked up the word woman
i mean what does the word woman
mean to the taliban okay and i found an
answer i found it in the dictionary it
says a woman
a woman
uterus procreator
okay
so uh now i understand why they have
that women should only give birth
and raise children okay
so now you know where that comes from
and uh
you know there's a fellow who uh
in fact uh seems to agree with them you
know and he put a note and this goes
like this he says i didn't say
ask women they'll give up their
privileges willingly willingly of course
they won't i said take their privileges
away from them
meaning totally disregard for what they
want
um i'm not sure too many women will
agree with him but what i can say is
that you know uh i think he found his
calling uh he should probably travel to
afghanistan become
a taliban
what do you think i mean you know let me
know
i think he's um
he's uh not part of this part of the
world he should you know maybe join the
taliban okay that would probably be his
calling
okay another thing in the news related
to
extinction in this case population
as uh i've been arguing you know
population will increase at a slower
rate as time goes by from now on
we have no chance of increasing the rate
of growth of population
meaning we can't increase demand
coupled with the fact that
we're in a
uh service economy
i think those two things are
seal our fate
okay
and so here in the news we have uh one
case uh mr putin he says
russia seeks to stimulate the birth rate
says president vladimir putin has
announced a series of plans to increase
the number of children being born in
russia from an average birth rate of
under 1.5 per woman to 1.7 within four
years
very ambitious plan okay on wednesday he
told parliament his parliament right the
duma uh the birth rate is falling again
yeah all these legislators i'll do
something about it before pledging state
funding for new mothers
and you know and they've been uh doing
this uh because this news is uh from
january 2020 but there was another one
now in august and they've been
putting out this kind of news for russia
for the last five six years at least
maybe more i've seen several articles
talking about the
dire problem that russia has
that its population is not increasing
and some people always uh tell me well
you know um
you know we should cover the land
and
uh or or they tell me that the world is
crowded
and it turns out russia is an empty
country
you know all the people are in big
cities you know the five six
cities russia has big cities that's it
you know uh
on the other side they're the euros
it's completely empty it's just bare
land uh not completely bare i mean it's
got trees and everything but i mean it's
under development land and if nobody
goes there and builds a new town
we're not going to have more population
in russia and the same can be said to
for australia
argentina
uh primarily those empty countries you
know algeria
they're big countries that uh
are not creating new cities they're not
colonizing the land okay
and so all i can suggest to him is that
there is a solution to um
to his problem you know and uh it came
from a bit of news that i found
somewhere else and it looks like this
and it says that uh paul is uh first
openly gay governor elected mary's in
colorado
and i said okay i looked down the
article and i found this note at the
bottom says
uh talking about his sweetheart right he
says they have been together for 18
years and have two children a
seven-year-old boy and a nine-year-old
girl
now i'm sure putin could learn from
these people i mean instead of
persecuting you know lgbt xyz and so on
why does he
encourage them to
have children like these two fellows did
okay
you know if uh if that happens i'm sure
the rate would increase in russia and
they could populate you know the other
side of the euros completely
so you know maybe he just should take
some pointers from these two fellows
okay
anyways um here uh we have a statistic
okay it says where women are having the
most children on the planet
and you can see the countries that are
mentioned there
they're not the biggest countries
population wise in the world
but what they are they all have in
common is that
most of their land is
or most of the people in their land are
agricultural they're still in the farms
they're still out there in the
wilderness
and uh so what is my argument my
argument
again i want people to quote me right
because they always misquote me my
argument is that
population stops when people come to the
cities
it's got nothing to do with uh
you uh you know the efforts that uh
non-governmental organizations ngos
do out there
all this work i mean that helps
one child per family china that helps
but the real problem the real problem is
when people come to the cities you can't
have children in the cities cities is
not a place a city is not a place to
raise children
and uh people have other things on their
mind and having children
and among them you know staying alive
one more day you know they can barely
reach the end of the month they're not
going to have 10 children like our great
grandfathers had you know uh
hundreds of years ago
so
the issue is that as long as you and
this gives you an idea because these are
all
agriculturalists countries still
they're backward countries in the sense
that people still have not come to the
cities you don't have big
great cities in these countries except
maybe one or two
the rest of the country is barren and
that's where most of people live and so
as long as people live in the country
they will have children when they come
to the city i don't care if they're poor
i don't care if they're black i don't
care if
the
the women are old or young they will not
have children
okay so it's got nothing to do with
uh i can't say it doesn't have to do
with money because money does play a
part in it
but the main ingredient is going from
the country to the city it's that
transition that stops population growth
okay that's my argument
whether you accept it or not uh that's
that is my argument so don't misquote me
okay and so here it doesn't matter what
these pure few countries do
uh you can see the rate has been
dropping steadily since 1963
and there is no end in sight and uh it
will continue to drop that's the growth
rate for the entire population on earth
that means that it doesn't matter what a
few countries in africa especially
do
they will not be able to reverse that
trend
that trend is
fixed guaranteed
can't change
and i
i even say that
the drop is going to be sooner because
extinction is going to occur before
2050 that's my take on that okay so
i don't think we're going to make it to
2050 zero population growth zero
population growth is going to occur much
much sooner
okay um
here's another bit of news concerns uh
extinction this one you should really
keep in mind okay uh
several headlines here uh one from the
examiner the world is a jungle france
fumes
at u.s australian nuclear submarine deal
they made a deal there military stuff
okay they sold some uh submarines to
australia and because of that australia
is not buying
some hardware from france so the french
are upset
okay
and then china also is not very happy
with that a cold war mentality china
slams new u.s pact with uk and australia
okay
and then just to add to that uh first we
have afghanistan the americans left
right american government decided to
leave afghanistan like it left vietnam
right
and it pulled some missiles out of saudi
arabia and yemen
and so the um the issue is whether
there's a
shifting
of
uh u.s resources military resources
from the middle east and europe
to the uh to the east to the toll east
is china a more important
adversary are a problem for the united
states than the middle east
so you know you only have so much so
many resources
and you got to find out how you're going
to
allocate those resources
and i think what you're seeing today
maybe it's been happening for some time
but now they're taking some of these
these major moves they're moving the
pawns on the chess board
okay
and i think the decision has been made
to
make a strategic
move and that is
use more resources
in the east than you do in the middle
east and even in europe it's like
we have europe in our back pocket we
have the middle east those countries
that are still loyal to the united
states that's in the back pocket as well
they're not going to go anywhere they're
not
probably going to switch sides at least
so easily you know maybe within they can
control that through diplomatic means
and meanwhile shift the hardware
to the east for the rising sun okay
that's what i think is happening
okay just a bit of news for you there to
ponder
uh another bit of news and this is uh an
interesting one okay it affects a lot of
people today
seven ways men live without working in
america
saying that since 1950 to today 70 years
now
the um
the number of men who work within
working age
that work
has been dropping
and today it was in the 80s 80 something
85 i think it was and today it's a
barely 66 67 percent
of working age men uh
that
are actually working all the rest
are stay at home dads or brothers or
sons or whatever
okay and these are the reasons the
article says that men are staying at
home okay unemployment insurance okay
you can include uh you know uh
social security with that i mean uh
i'm sorry i mean welfare okay
uh early retirement pensions
disability and lawsuits okay savings
trading stocks and bitcoin you know if
you can do bitcoin and you're doing okay
why are you going to get a job you know
working for cash you're under a table
black market okay
uh living off family family members okay
lots of people doing that
illegal work you know primarily drugs
yeah selling drugs and living off the
land you know guy says i'm sick of
society
i'm gonna go to the woods do some
fishing hunting carry my gun and live uh
you know like a real man should live
okay so uh those are
some of the things that are happening
out there
uh and what is interesting the uh the
rate of
women who work has gone up while the
those of men have gone down
so men are staying at home again with
brothers with uh
parents with uh whoever okay sometimes
alone
and women are going out there and
getting jobs and what they're doing what
the men are doing is living off the fat
of the land so to speak they find ways
of living without having to work okay
interesting uh trend okay
the question is whether that trend can
continue
you know it's uh for you to ponder
okay uh we have mr trump here another
bit of news he says uh predicts america
will end within three years
uh just the amount of time that i guess
mr biden has
uh as president
so he says america will come to a dead
stop in three years and then he said the
former president also hinted to newsmax
host sean spicer that he may run for the
presidency in 2024.
now why would anyone who thinks that
america is coming to an end in three
years
look for a job as the president
uh there seems to be a contradiction
there in my mind at least okay and i
don't have anything against mr trump i
want you to know that uh i'm just asking
a question i'm saying why would uh he
say the world is going to end in three
years or the united states for me it's
the world because if the united states
ends it's the end for the world but why
would he want to be president if the
united states comes to a dead stop
which exactly i mean he didn't specify
what he meant by that but
i'm assuming he means that you know
economically it's going to come to a
dead stop and
by inference
china is going to pass the united states
that's i guess what's going through his
mind
and
you know again uh
if if the united states comes to a dead
stop i think it's the end of the world
not not the end of america okay so we
have to bolster the united states any
way we can whether you like it or not
whether you're lovely the united states
government not irrelevant we have to
help the united states government stay
afloat because if it collapses we're all
in trouble that's my argument okay
that's my pitch to you okay one fellow
says hey don't worry about it he says uh
the united states will recover or the
economy the global economy will recover
says i disagree that it will be a
complete downfall after america
it will slow down trade and therefore
slow down a food across the globe but he
feels that it's gonna
somehow come back on its feet
it's just gonna be a dip another
depression another recession whatever
you want to call it
uh i think that
if there is a collapse
i call it extinction not depression okay
but again that's me all i can say is
that i cannot imagine
us recovering from the next major
collapse okay
okay another fellow has a different
opinion he says i never said u.s would
become part of the chinese empire one
thing i suggested the other day that if
the united states falls back
uh some people are
maybe insinuating that uh
united states gonna be a province
a state
of of china
just one of the
colonies out there you know the
uh
econ small economies that pay tribute to
the big empire
the new rome
that's the the insinuation right china
is not part of a western empire okay the
west is doomed whoa
the western nations are using the great
reset that's uh i talked about it a
little bit the other day you know we
have this fellow uh
schwab
and uh he created this notion of
the great reset where
um essentially there's gonna be a new
world order in which money is not gonna
be a problem uh in fact he says
something along the lines i can't
remember the exact words uh that you're
not going to have a penny but you're
going to be happy
so uh
quite different than what when i went to
college uh one professor
said the first day of class is in this
class
we're going to define happiness as money
if you have money you are happy
economics professor
the western nations are using the great
reset and kovit to introduce incremental
authoritarianism so they can default
under debt and pivot to electronic money
they can
then print without borrowing in uh
modern monetary theory well they can
print money without bitcoin uh i mean
they've been printing money
for as long as i can remember okay so
printing money is no big deal today in
fact all you need to do is just put
another zero in the computer and you got
another billion another trillion you
know
in the loop
so creating money is no big deal okay
and they've been doing that with
electronic money they will also be able
to completely control what the
population used that money for and tax
every cent in true marxist fashion uh
this is again uh comes from this fellow
schwab for those of you who are not
familiar with him and he's talking about
the great reset okay
and so this all got that information
from mr schwab right they will be fail
as uh marxism always fails at this time
maybe billions will die fulfilling part
of your theory okay no no
it's not part of my my entire theory is
that the entire system will collapse and
there will be no possibility even the
possibility of recovery okay when money
is no more meaning people lost faith and
money
in god we don't trust anymore you know
um
we don't accept money
and uh at that point you know
government the illuminati whoever you
you want up there has no control they
don't even have control over the army
they don't have control of the
government they don't have control over
anything because money is no more nobody
will accept money how do you compel
without money
okay so if money disappears
compulsion disappears
and by compulsion i don't mean you know
putting a gun to your head in in that
sense i mean that you know you go to
work as a policeman as a
guardsman whatever uh only because they
pay you
and because you need to make a living
and so uh you're expecting a salary but
if you're not expecting a salary why are
you going to go
go to work
more than likely you're going to use
your gun for something else all right
it will help me fail okay and what that
when that happens sometime in the 2030s
okay he's very optimistic we will have
our opportunity to create something new
in government
something new in government i'm
wondering uh what he's referring to uh
what kind of government do you plan to
have
if uh the economy collapses
and i mean you know total collapse
i mean bitcoin is just a number in a
computer
even checking accounts or money in a
computer that's all they are
uh it's just an all these are just
numbers in there that's it it's it's all
abstract
and even if it were real if it were gold
something you exchanged with your hands
okay so what
if no one accepts your gold because it
has no value
it's just a rock
you know a piece of stone
and nobody wants that piece of stone
anymore he wants a piece of limestone or
whatever
then
money is no more your gold is useless
your diamond is useless your pearls your
your bitcoin your dollar bills your
euros all that's worthless
you go to the store nobody wants it
you want to pay someone his salary in
money and he doesn't accept it
okay and so the question is can that
happen
and a lot of people say no it can't
happen.
and so they confuse the word can with
the word will
okay you got to distinguish between can
and will one of my papers i had to
state that because it's not so obvious
to a lot of people can it happen sure it
can happen in fact i can uh do a little
thought experiment and show you that it
can happen all the people in the world
all the
rulers
get together and they decide no not that
kobit
is gonna go no
they decide
that money is no more everyone that
shuts down
their own money everybody in
in each of the countries they decide to
eliminate money
can they do that well i'm saying they
can because i'm i'm saying that's
something we have within our power okay
we have the ability to destroy money if
we want to deliberately
can we
can we can
if we want to we can
we can destroy money tomorrow we can
destroy all the computers tomorrow and
there's no more money
all this fake money that's all this
abstract money so can we yes can we can
will we that's a separate question
so we should not confuse will with can
okay and that's important because if we
can
then we can still fit extinction within
that can
scenario okay if we can we can destroy
humanity today without throwing the
bombs all we have to do is destroy money
today deliberately
by maybe killing all the computers
anyway you want okay we can say money is
no more we all agree that money is no
more yeah we destroy the economy
so can we can will we that's a separate
issue okay so do not confuse can with
will
okay so what was this fellow talking
about he's talking about this fellow um
uh well
this fall it goes against uh the
previous one uh uh carl schwab uh please
look up ernst wolf he says okay so i
look him up and uh he has this um
this uh
video in which he says uncovering the
corona narrative
and uh what does he say well these are
the main points that he's got there the
style he talks against
uh this new world order specifically all
this covet uh thing that's going on okay
so he's dead set against it he says this
is a hoax
it was prepared by the government's
pre-planned
okay that's what his argument is okay
says we're dealing with a complete
destruction of the global financial
system but we are also on the threshold
of reshuffling of a global strategic
order again a lot of these people think
that we're getting rid of one order and
replacing it with some kind of some
other kind of order okay this this is
what's going through their minds well
everybody thinks in the same way they're
so sick and tired of the politicians
they say we got to get rid of all this
and so
they say okay we get rid of this what do
we replace it with
and so you know you have the communist
and the capitalist the capital to say
well we're going to be trading with our
neighbors and we don't we get government
off our backs okay they're the
anarcho-capitalists and the other guys
we'll call them the communists for lack
of a better word uh we get rid of all
the money and we all live happily ever
after uh i don't know how maybe
exchanging goods or whatever just
everybody is happy if they could get
government off their backs
and the question is can we live with our
without government you know we're a
social animal we created government can
we get rid of this big monster this uh
um
you know uh
what is it
this monster we created is running a
mock it was thinking of um
not einstein
i was thinking of the other foul i can't
remember the name but uh okay it says
big credit bubble over in the world ever
in the world okay we got a big credit
bubble uh
uh loans that need to be repaid can't be
paid anymore this guy's supposedly a uh
an expert
in
economics he's a journalist who
specializes in economics okay so the
system is beyond
saving okay
uh the derivatives bubble 700 trillion i
talked about that in the past okay and i
got the same number somewhere
uh we don't know how much
it is but this is a
a ballpark figure okay 700 trillion
we are in the final phase of this
financial system we are witnessing
diluting uh orgy by major investors
okay so he's saying that the reason this
kovit was created so that they could do
all this looting behind our backs
okay
well uh there's a lot of um
you know conspiracy in his language and
some of it is okay some of it may not be
at least from my point of view
uh
what i agree with him is that the system
is collapsing
that that we agree where we don't agree
is that he believes that
there is salvation at the end of the
line you know and one of the ways you do
salvation is by opposing what these
people are trying to do today okay and a
lot of people are in tune with that they
say i'm not gonna follow i'm not gonna
get my vaccine you know etc and uh and
they
protest against the
you know the government for forcing them
to do something they don't want to do
and my only concern there with this
covet is turning this into a conspiracy
and no one has been able to answer that
question even this fall he hasn't even
raised it none of them have raised it
and the issue is
is it possible that cuba which is an
enemy of the united states iran which is
an enemy of the united states and so on
and so forth that they all agreed
in advance
before this covet came out did they all
agree and
say let's do this conspiracy all
together all the governments on earth we
all agree
that we're going to create this covid
and we're going to tell our people each
one in his own country right both
enemies and and
and friends
we're all going to agree to tell our
populations our respective populations
that there's this disease out there
that's going to kill us and so that's
going to force them to get the shots and
meanwhile we loot the banks somehow and
some behind their backs
well you know i doubt that happened
you know i have until someone can answer
that question for me
i have to believe there is a virus out
there okay for those of you who believe
in virus because that's another group
okay
but for those of you who believe in
viruses okay
and
do you really think that all these
governments in advance before where was
it
2019 december or thereabouts or
beginning of 2020
they already said before that in advance
that they were all going to do this to
their own populations and they're going
to create this inexistent problem saying
hey we got this covered everybody's got
to get a shot and blah blah blah
and distract people's attention from the
real problem which is the economy
and meanwhile they through the economy
told everybody go home we're going to
send you a paycheck and don't bother
even to come to work because maybe there
is no work okay
and so on down the line and so i doubt
that everybody
uh that this was premeditated
now there is a twist of that the only
one that i can allow in my mind okay and
that's that you know the united states
went to this town in
china
uh what was in 2019 there was a military
get-together
and according to chinese the americans
brought the covet with them and
according to americans the covets
started in that city because the chinese
created it in the lab okay so each one
is pointing their fingers at each other
great
it could have been that someone created
this virus maybe i don't know
i don't know enough about that topic all
i can say is
that's the only way i can conceive of a
premeditated uh action where someone
created it for whatever reason maybe for
the reason i just explained you know to
be able to loot the banks and change the
system and they threw it out into the
world and in countries like cuba and
iran had no choice but to accept the
fact that some of their people were
getting sick
and so it's not that they agreed in
advance but they took care of the
problem once the problem was upon them
and that's the only scenario that i can
see other than
the covet being
no conspiracy whatsoever just something
that arose out there okay so those are
the two possibilities but if someone
could tell me why all these governments
agreed
uh then i'll i'll rest
better at nights
okay uh so here are my questions for all
those people who want to tackle them
okay was the rise of women inevitable
you know the fact that women uh
match to us you know are
us meaning men
uh so we have women that came up and men
who came down you know a little bit and
so they kind of uh are demanding their
rights was that inevitable
was uh giving women the vote inevitable
i mean almost every country on the
planet in fact i think all of them give
women the vote today i don't know if
there's any exception
and 100 years ago it wasn't like that in
fact a hundred years ago women did not
more than a little more than 100 years
ago women did not have the right to vote
and so yeah they've come up
the ranks right they've
become our equals
was the increase in homosexuality among
humans inevitable
was that uh
[Music]
something that they people just came out
of the closet or is it something that
changed in our genetic code
right
was the economic expansion of the
chinese empire inevitable and if it
wasn't china it could have been someone
else right
was that inevitable for another empire
to rise
and
[Music]
challenge the american empire
you know there's always been empires
that
have risen and fallen you know and when
one fell the other one rose okay and so
was that inevitable is this like
mandated by history
is that the way mother nature compels
men to behave
create new empires
i mean we have new companies
remember companies in the past were
manufacturing companies
primarily and they've been replaced by
web by a lot of these uh
internet companies you know facebook
amazon
they're all internet internet companies
and so uh yeah one empire comes down
which is all this manufacturing stuff
anyone who put their bets on that
and what rose were the internet uh
empires
so again we see that there as well
and then um
related to that were the results of
calhoun's utopian experiments inevitable
okay and that's related to extinction
and there you see it at the bottom uh
that's uh taken from calhoun's
uh
experiment i think that's number 25 and
he put a bunch of mice uh about uh four
pairs
of mice in a
a an enclosure
and he let him reproduce and uh they
overflowed
there were over two thousand mice after
a little while and
then the
population crashed went into extinction
you had to stop the experiment at the
last moment because you just couldn't
see
the results how the how the whole thing
ended it just was for him he had seen it
several times he did many experiments
and so he didn't want to see it again so
he shut it down
okay but uh it was going into extinction
they weren't reproducing anymore
sounds like humans
but a lot of people question that they
say no no this is a little different
okay
okay
so let's move on to physics
strictly physics now we're going to do
another uh version of how mother nature
does opacity
and um transparency
i mentioned three ways that mother
nature deals with opacity and
transparency
the opaque and the transparent
and one of them the way she does it is
uh with alignment
that's my argument okay i'm saying that
one of the ways she does it is with
alignment and uh what i showed was that
you know we took a couple lenses they
were
these polarized lenses and if you can
see there you can see that light
disappears when uh at the end of the
black screen here um when when the uh
lenses are perpendicular to each other
but when they're parallel uh the light
goes through so it's transparent in one
direction but when the molecules are
rotated
uh it's now longer transparent now it's
opaque okay so if you were at the other
end of that laser you know the laser
pointing to your eye you would see it
when the when the two lenses are
parallel but when they're uh
perpendicular uh the light does not
reach your eye okay and that's what i'm
showing there i'm saying that the
molecules okay
uh calcium carbonate uh when they're
rotated they're now misaligned okay
and one of the ways you can do that is
uh that way which is
the ropes that were connected from one
atom to the other straight ahead
are no longer uh
you know in in
parallel direction to the
laser or the beam that's coming in there
okay
the other way i suggest it is that uh by
rotating what you're doing is twisting
the rope okay and by twisting it
90 degrees
okay
you're actually changing the uh
linked lengths okay by by a certain
amount
an amount enough to take it out of the
visible range okay that's why becomes
opaque or transparent
and one fellow questioned that okay
that's good that people questioning says
when you rotate the lens 90 degrees the
rope also rotates would that not then
imply that if you were spinning the lens
with a motor you would rotate the rope
more and more thus changing the
frequency of any light entering those
molecules okay
is it not more likely that the turning
of the lens 90 degrees would not change
the link lengths because the whole
electron shell in fact is like a
slippery ball that spins to keep the
ropes at the same orientation much like
a bubble
okay
good input
and uh i'm not going to give him an
answer yet
i want to continue okay let me continue
and maybe we can find
the answer he's looking for okay
uh
one fellow says
explain transparency in materials where
the atoms are not aligned like in the
water
the water is transparent whether still
or in motion you know that water
molecules are constantly in motion don't
you
do you lose transparency just for a
moment when the molecules move
you say that the alignment is not the
only mechanism that explains the
transparency and then you spend
several minutes explaining water
transparency by the alignment of water
molecules
okay so let's address
both gentlemen here okay
kill two birds with one stone
first of all nowhere
nowhere did i say
the first person just suggesting the
second one is
is stating oh you said this
now uh the reason he
said this uh
mentioned that
comment is that he wasn't paying
attention when i was talking he was busy
talking himself and so
you know when you're talking you don't
listen well yeah you're not going to
understand what's going on here what's
going on here is
i'm not here to give you answers
okay i'm not here to give you answers
i'm here to provide you with the tools
necessary for you to figure it out on
your own
you know
if you go back to the ancient greece
right
he had socrates
and allegedly he
got together with his uh pupils his
students
and you know he never wrote anything and
again you know it's uh the victors who
usually write history in this case he
wasn't a victor because he was forced to
drink hemlock
but you know his students wrote about
him and you can only go by what they
tell us among them plato and xenophon uh
later on uh student of plato you know uh
aristotle uh he he also mentioned them
socrates
and the way apparently socrates dealt
with his students was when they asked
the question
he would typically answer with another
question
and it's a good method because it throws
the ball back
to the student and the student now has
to think
if the if if you just give them the
answer and say this is the answer so
okay i'll memorize that for the test
and so he hasn't really
grasped what you were telling him
because it was a freebie so he said okay
i see i see what you're saying
and he didn't see anything
and so the issue here is i'm not here to
tell you
how transparency and opacity is done i'm
here to give you clues
of how mother nature
does transparency here in this situation
in this situation in this other
situation
and i'm showing you that also parallel
to that that you cannot explain those
situations transparency opacity
with waves or particles
quantum
you cannot explain you cannot give a
physical interpretation to opacity and
transparency using
the waves and particles of mathematical
physics that's where the problem is
and so i'm contrasting the rope model
against that and i'm showing you that
under the rope you have all these
options one of them like i'm saying is
twisting the rope the other one is the
rope itself goes out of alignment
because you know you suddenly you know
move that thing around and so now the
light from the laser does not go through
the same ropes to reach that
first the second
slab
and then the screen
i'm just giving you clues
you're supposed to give me
the answer
okay and nowhere did i say hopefully i i
didn't say
that either air or water or glass is
because of alignment
okay
i'm giving you an example of something
to
to keep in mind
when you're looking at all these
transparent media
okay
and so people confuse and say oh bill
said no no i didn't say anything
i didn't say how um
why
so far i haven't said as far as i know
so far i haven't said why air water or
glass are transparent
okay i'm giving you clues
what to reject what to accept okay so
you're supposed to figure out why air
water and glass are transparent and
brick walls are not
okay
second issue i said well one is uh
alignment one thing to keep in mind i
did say by the way yes i did say that in
the case of polarizers it is the 90
degree turning of the molecules okay
that i did say it's the only one i said
so far okay other than that i haven't
talked about air water or glass i'm not
telling you
why they're
transparent i'm suggesting you look at
the fact that even though like this fall
says water moves air moves the question
is when you rotate water
does the molecule rotate as well or does
the water remain
at the same
in the same direction with respect to
the center of the earth gravity in other
words that's the issue
okay
for you to ponder
do the molecules of water stand under
side you know oxygen
hydrogen oxygen
hydrogen
if they're like that do they also stand
like that despite that the
water level you can see that the water
when when you turn that glass around the
water stands still more or less it moves
a little bit but you know water remains
level with respect to the center of the
earth gravity does play a role
in uh in in water for some reason does
it play a role inside a balloon full of
air does the air also turn on its side
the double o
oxygen or the nitrogen that's in there
whatever's in there does it turn on its
side or does it remain
always in the same direction with
respect to the center of the earth i'm
trying to give you clues to get you to
think
okay let's see if that sinks in
okay uh we did quantity and here we put
a single sheet
and the seat looked like this okay
okay just a little plastic uh here it is
okay
you can see it's just a little plastic
and a very thin sheet
and when i put many sheets okay uh you
can see the the light from the candle
doesn't show through so quantity is also
important
apparently mother nature if she has a
very
thin sheet of something
she may allow light to go through but
when she has many sheets of whatever
you know many of those then light does
not go through
so she built opacity with many
transparencies
okay
second clue it's a clue okay did i say
is that the reason
water air or glass is transparent i
haven't said any okay so i haven't said
that okay
okay um so where do we go from here well
a couple people had problems with that
okay and let's see what they have here's
the first one foul says
says of course you know that when light
is
equal on both sides it appears as a
mirror but you can also see through to
the other side he's talking about you
know one-way mirrors okay
you can see yourself in a mirror and the
person on the other side can see you
and how can that possibly be here we
have
you you think it's a mirror the other
guy for the other guy it's a glass it's
a transparent glass he can see you and
you can't see him
okay and so he's saying when light is
equal on both sides it appears as a
mirror but you can also see through to
the other side okay
uh
thank god someone mentioned that uh we
didn't know that
okay and here's another fella uh you can
get him here give me a second
and he says the same thing he says
polarized lenses are coated
a one-way mirror works similar to
polarization
a mirror has aluminum one side of the
glass and we can see through it the
one-way mirror has to have the lighting
double the brightness on one side for
the illusion to work
so neither of these two fellows paid any
attention at all whatsoever to what i
said okay
they think it's got to do something with
lighting
and
um the one-way mirror has to do with
lighting in the room okay
it has nothing to do with the question
with the issue that i addressed
so they're barking up a tree they're
they're beating up um
a scarecrow dragging him through the mud
because they're not addressing the issue
let's see if they can understand the
issue what the issue is
i don't think they will they probably
don't have the capacity to understand
this okay so let's let's go slowly at
least for for the
mentally disadvantaged
people who come here okay
let's get rid of all the lighting
okay you want to put the lighting put
the lighting i don't care
it's irrelevant to the question at hand
okay with the issue that i'm going to be
addressing now okay
we have a laser pointed from one
direction
and we know that that laser the laser
goes through the light from the laser
the photons of the laser not of the room
but of the laser okay
so the photons that make up that laser
beam that ray those are going through
okay because i can see the laser from
the other side i can see everything in
the room from the other side
but it turns out the person on this side
cannot see the laser
the photons coming out of my laser that
are going through
and instead of bouncing
because they don't it's a glass again
but
it's the same glass for both of us right
mine don't go through
uh i'm sorry uh he can't see the guy on
the other side of the mirror he can't
see my laser
but i can see his
and the first question is is the
material
that make up that uh mirror
this one-way mirror
is it the same in either direction
as the amount of
material has the amount of
molecules atoms changed
why am i bringing this up i'm bringing
this up because the
uh explanation that quantum mechanics
gives to this phenomenon has nothing to
do with lighting in the room
okay let's see if you understand this it
has the quantum explanation has nothing
to do with lighting in the room
it has to do with whether an electron of
that material that you see there of the
glass coated or uncoated i don't care
whether the material
absorbs a photon
it's the same material either in either
direction
okay it's got coating on one side
doesn't it on the other side i don't
care it's irrelevant the material is the
same in other words the material that
the rays of the photons have to pass
through is the same either way
do we understand that or not does it has
it sunk in this it's the same material
so the question is why does
the electron of one of those atoms that
builds that glass that coated glass
why does it accept this
uh
photon and does not allow it to go
through
and why does it in the opposite
direction
accept that that does not accept that
photon the photon scout is supposed to
supposed to
kick the electron to a higher energy
level right it doesn't do that and so it
goes by and you can see it
it's the same material in either
direction
so we're addressing quantum mechanics
here forget about your lighting it's
nonsense it has nothing to do with the
question at hand
okay
so here's uh what i showed
uh maybe they watch it i don't know
this is how quantum mechanics explains
uh
both uh well
this this serves for both cases for
transparency and opacity what are we
staring at here we see a little photon
it hits the electron which is at a lower
energy level and it knocks it into a
higher energy level
we say that the electron absorbs the
photon
when it does that the photon doesn't get
through
okay
on the other hand you know
if the
electron
if the photon doesn't come with
sufficient energy and doesn't kick it to
the higher the electron to a higher
energy level
then it goes by it zips by and that's
when you can see it that's when the
material is transparent according to
quantum mechanics
okay
so again if the material
the only thing that blocks
the rays of light in either direction
okay
if the material is the same
why would it absorb
the photon in one direction and not
absorb it in the other that is the
question
okay so don't talk about lighting it has
nothing or coding and has nothing to do
with the question at hand
okay let's see if we can continue
and i guess because these people don't
listen they're not paying attention they
just want to see what they what they
learned in college what they memorize in
college is oh but it's got coding oh but
the lighting in the room they're not
listening
okay uh temperature i said that's
another factor we got to consider when
we look at transparency and opacity okay
and what i did i took a glass and i let
i put a
pen in there and froze it and then i
just uh
let it outside let it
melt the ice and i filmed it every
10
15 20 minutes and there you can see what
happens suddenly you know the pen comes
into view it was not visible when the
ice was solid
and it's visible when the ice melted so
uh temperature did something okay
apparently temperature has some bearing
on opacity that was my argument okay and
you can see something similar at the
bottom where you see a
pot boiling you have that water come out
of steam and it's hot
and apparently the temperature did
something to the water because the water
inside that pot would be transparent but
the one there with all that smoke coming
out that's not transparent that foggy
thing
so temperature apparently has something
something okay to do with transparency
and opacity okay
did i say that water is uh
transparent because of heat no no i'm
saying i'm giving you clues
all the things you got to factor when
you ponder why something is opaque or
transparent that's what i'm saying i'm
giving you tools okay please understand
the situation here okay
okay and here uh we continue
um
uh fella says you better not use water
becoming opaque when it freezes in the
next video because those are air bubbles
reflecting and scattering it's almost
easy to make ice as clear as liquid
water and not hard to find pictures of
it online
okay so he's saying that
ice and water are both completely
transparent identically i transparent
and that my experiment really did not
prove anything or show anything or
whatever to him at least
because
um he said
what i did was trap bubbles
in other words that water had more air
i guess you could say more air than
water
and uh that by capturing all those
bubbles you know that's what made the
water opaque okay well it could be uh
that's i'm almost sure that's the case
but i just want to show you something
okay for you to reach your own
conclusions again uh here's uh different
pictures of ice that like the fella set
you can find a lot of pictures of ice
out there
and i haven't seen that they are very
clear as clear as water
the other thing i want to mention if you
look at all these pictures out there
okay and if you google them you'll find
that they all have to do with
commercials
you know they're companies who are
trying to sell you a machine
that makes ice
and so they'll say look our machine
makes great ice and if you put this ice
and you do it this way and this one that
way you'll get clear ice pure ice and
it's crystal clear
so so they're giving you a sales pitch
and that's what most of these pictures
are all about they're about you know
selling
have they done anything uh very like
a lot of people say scientifically in
other words did they do a controlled
experiment
and the answer is probably not okay
they just say look if you boil water get
rid of the water the
gas the air bubbles
then you're gonna and you freeze that uh
then you're gonna have a better chance
of having crystal clear ice okay
but if you look at some of the pictures
out there you know uh
the jury's still out for me okay
you look at clear ice and it doesn't
look so clear to me okay and that's just
one picture i pulled out of at random
okay
here's another one and i just want you
to look at these pictures okay
and comparison against water
and i don't know uh i still say that ice
even if you
do it perfectly well
get rid of all the air bubbles whatever
nitrogen whatever is in there okay
i'm not sure you're gonna get it as
crystal clear as water
pure water versus pure ice
i i think that ice uh
is a tiny itsy bitsy
uh more opaque than water okay
okay so you don't believe me
don't believe me don't accept
what i just said let's go further i did
mention this and that's argon
is solid it's more or less transparent
liquid it's also more or less
transparent
in a gaseous state
the opposite okay in a gas you stay
heated right at room temperature
it's opaque
so here we have the opposite effect
okay
we went here in the other case we went
from
um liquid to solid here we go from solid
to liquid to gaseous
and it becomes opaque
in that direction
okay
so uh
my argument was what
temperature has something to do with
opacity that was my sole argument did i
say that water is opaque because of um
because of um
heat did i say that air is a uh
i'm sorry transparent because of heat no
i'm just giving you the tools
to look at all the factors that govern
transparency and opacity okay so
let's keep the context in the right
place right okay um
so
so again one of the issues here is that
i'm not here to give you answers okay i
try not to give you answers if i can
help it i'm trying to get you to think
uh like socrates uh uh you answer ask a
question i'm gonna try to give you
clues and ask you a question
i think it's better it's
uh more healthy for your state of mind
okay it makes you think
means you understood what i'm saying if
i just give you the answers okay bill
said listen walk away you never
understood anything okay
okay that's one of the points the other
point is that i'm trying to make is you
know we got to destroy quantum mechanics
the nonsense of mathematical physics
which still 400 years later is still
doing all simulations with particles and
waves okay and so one fella asks he says
light is passing through glass he
insists that light travels
through
and so
yeah that's a statement you haven't said
anything because you haven't told us
what it is that is traveling through the
glass okay
are we talking about particles are we
talking about waves are we talking about
ghosts what are we what's going through
the glass
you have to identify the object if you
haven't identified the object you cannot
say travel through passing through goes
through you cannot use that term because
you haven't identified the object yet
okay so you need to identify the
physical object that is going through
the glass okay then you can say yeah see
uh i can show you a movie
of how
whatever a particle goes through the
glass or how a wave goes through a glass
and then of course you've got to
identify that object
and of course we know there's no such
thing as a wave because a wave is a
bunch of
particle
vectors
quantum is a concept that's a zero
dimensional point
particle
meaning it's a wave function collapse
which is a concept
and we don't move concepts in physics
so we have no particles and we have no
waves so you can't use the particle or
the wave so what is the physical object
that's going through the glass traveling
through the glass breaking through it
and it doesn't break it
now you have this photon going through
there all these bullets
and they don't break the glass
uh-huh
okay
and uh so a fellow insists he said wave
is both a noun and a verb light
wave has peak and trough
with and height width and length we can
see in touch with human perception you
can touch a wave
wave is an object oh
well again all we're seeing there are
vectors
what's a vector it's uh magnitude and
direction
and what these people are saying is that
uh we have magnitudes that are traveling
we have a number of fives that are
traveling number six is they're
traveling that's what they're saying
so no fives sixes sevens and eights
don't travel
you have to identify the physical object
that is traveling that is waving okay
and uh
yeah
they you know a lot of these people say
well you know we um
we have the math
we
have the equations to show you
that we measured
and we've um
put the observation in
the form of an equation so we describe
what's happening in there
well can an equation tell you
what physical entity what invisible
untouchable entity is doing light is
doing gravity is doing magnetism
you have the equation and here's the
equation okay you have an equation and
it shows a rabbit that is moving okay
well maybe that's what your equation
says but maybe what's happening is
something else maybe it's a snake that's
twirling in place maybe that's what the
invisible thing is
so maybe your equation is uh
for that invisible entity
is wrong in the sense that you think
there's something moving from a to b
from left to right and what's actually
happening is something is twirling
locally in place
in fact that's what a wave is
okay so so the question is
you know is
is the equation
going to tell you what invisible entity
you're
mapping
representing with that equation
okay so
you have to know what the object is and
for that there is no other way you can't
go to the lab because you're not going
to be able to see or touch it because by
the
definition it's invisible intangible
that's the description okay so you're
not going to be able to go to the lab
and use your eyes or your hands
to see that which is invisible or touch
that is intangible
the only way is to drink a beer go back
you know and
and think
this is something you have to try to
visualize
you visualize first then you can apply
the the equation that's the way it works
in science
you know if you want to describe it with
an equation go ahead
but right now what we need is a physical
object and right now we don't have a
physical object coming from mathematical
establishment but all those people who
talk about you know traveling through
that's what they got to come up with
they have to come up with the object
that is traveling through going through
moving through
we want to know what what is it that is
moving
okay uh because for all we know uh maybe
all you're doing is
describing the
humps of a camel that are moving up and
down locally
okay so what's the fourth one we had
alignment we have the quantity of
material right the different layers
and we have the temperature okay so we
have three clues now
that mother nature uses to govern
opacity and transparency
today let's look at crystal structure
okay
here we have a
transparent generally we have
gases or liquids
not all of them but a lot of them are
transparent and in general we associate
what is opaque no opacity we usually
associate that with um
stiff things with rigid
uh material okay we think of a brick
wall we say well that's not transparent
we think of a steel beam
we said well that's not transparent
so if someone asks you to name things
that are transparent you would say well
air water
glass
you name the usual suspects okay
you don't mention those things which are
generally
solid
okay of course you have tables which are
transparent and so on uh glass more or
less sounds looks solid right you can
touch it
it's quite solid but in general we
associate
transparency with malleable or soft
things whereas
hard things are typically opaque okay
and so i want to address that today and
just give you this other clue fourth
clue all right
and here's one way of looking at it i
want to show you this uh
i do it with a ball and i throw it
against the spring okay
and the spring is a pushover you know
you can push a spring almost anywhere
you want the spring itself is malleable
it uh deforms
okay
so um you would think that if light
behaves like that right
um
the spring would pass whatever motion is
given to it to whatever is behind it it
would you know send that same signal
behind it
meaning that maybe it's a
way that mother nature does transparency
in other words imagine the rope
giving a signal to that spring
and the spring is such a pushover that
just gives a signal to whatever's behind
it
okay on the other hand you know if you
do it with a tree right
well you know the ball doesn't uh really
the tree doesn't really pass it on that
vibration to whatever's behind it okay
it does receive a little vibration a
tiny bit right but the point is that it
doesn't it's not gonna move the world
behind it
and so i'm saying that maybe uh this
transparency
opacity has something to do with the
rigidity
of the molecules that form whatever body
you're analyzing okay but there's a
problem with that okay and let me show
you what the problem is so that you
balance that on the other side again
um
how about sound
you know you have uh
sound you make a noise
and it travels through the air
but it turns out that
sound travels faster
in liquids and even faster in solids
so you would think that
if i send sound waves
meaning that i'm not sending any wave
meaning
it vibrates locally right
if i send these sound waves just to
speak like that okay i'm going to use
that language you would think that
if a solid thing
transfer transfers that sound faster you
would think that that would be the means
for transparency for light
and
it would be the other way around in
other words uh it would be solid things
rigid things which would transfer which
would be transparent like steel and uh
i mean walls brick walls
and not air and water
because again they're pushovers and
maybe if sound is a good analogy for
light
maybe it works the other way around
okay so maybe that kind of balances it
out you can have arguments on both sides
on that now it's important to understand
that sound you know
uh is built with molecules
molecules are vibrating in situ
okay
and i showed that the other day
okay
okay and first here we see
solids versus liquid and gas you can see
that sound travels faster in solids than
in liquids and liquids faster than in
gases okay
so uh and it's due to the um
density of the molecules that build up
that build up those materials
okay
so
uh that's one thing to ponder but here
we see um
that you know the water the waves are
local
you know because when i talk the
molecule that i'm vibrating here in in
the air that's not what the one that
reaches your ear
and even even in a steel beam
if i send sound through a steel beam
the molecule that i vibrate at the
beginning of the steel beam is not going
all the way through the steel beam to
your ear at the other end
okay it more or less works like this
everything vibrates in place and you
receive the final vibration from the
atoms molecules that are close to your
ear
okay which again vibrates the air that's
close to your ear okay
so so the issue is there's no traveling
through that's the main point okay
this notion of traveling through first
has to die but then the question is if
sound is a good analogy for light
you have to remember huygens you know
christian higgins
when he
simulated light he used water waves as
an analogy he said what if we drop a
stone in the water and we create these
waves and maybe light is like these
water waves
well obviously he was wrong you know but
i mean it was a good first attempt no
problem there but
it turned out that that's not the way
light behaves and so the question is
can we use sound
as a
simulator for
light as well and the first thing i have
to point out is that in space
sound doesn't work
okay
now this is important for several
reasons the first one is that
light does work in space
light goes from the andromeda galaxy
through space
we'll use that traveling through space
somehow light reaches us from the under
arm of the galaxy so uh space does not
seem to be an impediment for light on
the other hand uh sound does not travel
from one astronaut to the other through
the space right here in our solar system
you know they're both on the moon
um which is uh with 10 to the minus 11
torr
very few molecules in in that at that
level
and so an astronaut would not be able to
talk even if he took his you know thing
off and he could talk right he would not
be able to talk to the other person and
or the other person would not be able to
hear him because there's nothing to
carry
to use that term the uh sound waves
there's no material to vibrate locally
as you just saw
okay
light goes through
sound does not go through space okay and
so if that's the case you know uh here
let me
let me show you uh an example here uh if
uh space is made out of particles as uh
quantum mechanics holds as mathematical
physics holds they say that space itself
is made out of particles
and if that's the case then why is it
that
light goes through you can say well yeah
because it's made out of particles how
come sound doesn't go through
if
if those particles are there if all the
space is made out of particles why don't
they vibrate when we talk through space
okay we have a problem there because
they use
space they say space is made out of
particles
but um those particles uh do not carry
sound
well why not i mean why don't they wave
when sound goes through there
and some people say well bill you're
wrong you get it wrong no one ever said
that space is made out of particles
okay so let's prove them wrong let's
prove these people wrong so that they
never open their mouth again okay let's
show them
what quantum says okay because they
don't know their own religion okay
the quantum bank this is the first part
is from the wikipedia the other is from
another website but you can look it up
anywhere you want just look up uh for
example
pear production and you'll find out that
yes quantum says that space is made out
of particles
the direct sea space is made out of
particles they're all saying the same
thing they've been saying it for 100
years so if you haven't been listening
that's your problem okay the quantum
vacuum or quantum state is the quantum
state with or vacuum state is the
quantum state with the lowest possible
wet energy whatever energy is what is it
a concept
okay you might say well energy is a
concept so so what do they say they say
the space is made out of concepts
quantum foam also known as space-time
foam or space-time bubble is the quantum
fluctuation of space-time what is
space-time a concept right what is time
is in time of concept okay they're
talking about the fluctuation of time
you know it's about it's fluctuating
it's moving it's vibrating time itself
the second is moving up and down five
seconds
okay on very small scales due to quantum
mechanics matter and anti-matter is
constantly created and destroyed i don't
know what destroyed means because
they blend and they form what nothing
two particles get together they form
nothing and then they come out of
nothing and form two particles
they're just cheating they're saying
that a black particle
and a white particle will form a no
particle and the
no particle can separate into white and
black particle what they're really
saying is well we don't want to call
that one in the center a particle
and so they say it disappears whatever
that means what does this appear mean
what did the particles turn into
they turned into nothing what is nothing
please define the word nothing
what is it a particle is it a ball or
what does nothing look like
okay so the issue here is these people
are cheating because they're saying we
have two balls they get together and
they form a no ball
and they say a no ball but they don't
define what a no ball is in other words
nothing
and then they say from the no ball from
nothing suddenly two
two particles two balls come out of
there
it's cheating
of course uh
fangman says nobody understands quantum
mechanics how can you understand if you
give me an irrational explanation and
trying to get away with it okay a vacuum
is defined as a space with as little
energy in it as possible
always that word energy it fills all the
blanks
despite the name the vacuum still has
what quantum fields fields what is a
field a concept
numbers that's what a field is bunch of
numbers that's all it is
uh
potential at each point in space that's
constant
according to quantum mechanics particle
pairs
particle pairs are constantly appearing
and disappearing as a quantum phone
okay so is the vacuum made out of
particles of course it is
they just don't say it that way and
that's why you missed it but that's what
they're saying
and the this other side says pair
production is the opposite of
annihilation so we have annihilation two
particles form
annihilate whatever they turn into the
zip
and then zip
whatever zip is turns into two particles
well i have to believe that zip is a
particle itself
uh what is zip what is this nothing
is it a ball
two particles turn into one ball
what is this zip unless you define that
you haven't said anything
okay
mysteriously particles can appear from
nowhere
yeah that's called magic it's not called
science called magic black magic
okay so um yeah if first of all um
quantum does say mathematical physics
does say general relativity does say
that part of that uh the vacuum space is
made out of particles space-time
warpage what is warping a whole bunch of
particles a point at each uh what's an
event is a point in space-time what is
that point it's a thing
that's what they insinuate okay so the
physical interpretation is that yeah
space is made out of particles
okay until you understand that you
haven't understood anything of
mathematical physics of quantum
mechanics of general relativity so get
that through your thick skull
space is made out of particles according
to quantum mechanics according to
mathematical physics but then if that's
the case why does light which is the
vibration of all that ether right
why doesn't sound do the same thing if
space is made out of particles why don't
those particles vibrate and i can hear
sound through space
see that's when they introduce the
vacuum the space and they say well
there's nothing there and that's why you
need molecules in there why do i need
molecules why don't can't i do with the
particles of space
that's the question
okay so what are the conclusions today
well we have uh four variables now okay
for you to ponder okay when analyzing
transparency and opacity under the rope
model of light okay
alignment
quantity temperature and today we have
molecular structure i'm saying that if
rigidity has something to do
with in general
with um
how light is whether light is trans
whether the material is transparent or
not okay opaque
and what is this whole thing all about
well it's got nothing to do with me
saying that
uh
water is transparent because the
molecules are aligned never said that
never will okay
don't ask what bill can do for you ask
what you can do for bill
don't ask tell your job is to tell me
how uh or tell yourself you don't have
to tell me necessarily
i'm not your confessor
um
figure out by yourself using these clues
why
glass water air are transparent
and a brick wall is not
i'm giving you the clues the tools for
you to figure it out
okay
that's that's the context
okay let's move on to the questions or
comments that people made
uh here's uh one fellow
and he says
is it rational to propose a model which
can only be comprehended when divided
from its parts you're talking about uh
the rope you know i'm talking about a
rope between two atoms it's like i chop
it off there and just analyze you know
the two atoms in one rope so he said
you're chopping that we can understand
that but he says gazillions the ropes
are not imaginable but a few yes uh yeah
can you imagine gazillions of worms
i mean if you want i can put a gazillion
more in there you know i mean
it's one of those things that
it's irrelevant
the fact that you cannot comprehend
gazillions of
atoms
or even gazillions of particles of
quantum mechanics
i mean it's it's irrelevant if quantum
mechanics proposes look the entire
universe is just full of
particles
oh i cannot imagine i can't wrap my head
around that you don't have to
you don't have to you don't have to with
a rope you don't have to build a
particle you don't have to waves either
they're all over the place okay all
these things so you know
to say that you cannot imagine it you
don't have to make it you just have to
answer
specific questions you gotta answer how
does light work how does gravity work
how does magnetism work for that you
don't need the gazillions of ropes and
uh
atoms and uh particles that are out
there in the universe
okay we tackle one problem at a time
you're trying to you're trying to say
well i can't visualize the universe with
so many
uh planets and stars yeah i mean look
out on the
outside tonight and you'll see a lot of
stars all over the place and you say
it's unimaginable
you're seeing it you're visualizing it
yeah it is unimaginable so we got a lot
of stars out there and we're just a
little tiny planet in in the in the
universe
okay it's unimaginable of course it is
and so is god he's unimaginable okay
another fellow insists he says something
about a laser he says one atom bad many
atoms bad no explanation still pretty
lame okay does it matter i was just
responding to your complaint about one
atom explain the coherence then
and all i can say to this poor fellow is
that he's been beating around the bush
on um
using 10 atoms
to create a directional uh
beam in the case of blazer and i'm
saying again these people have it wrong
because
in in to make a laser to orient it just
like a
horse you know you you have to put
something uh
to the sides of the horse so that the
horse looks straight ahead right
otherwise if you take that out the horse
has a peripheral vision
okay
and to say well a horse doesn't have
peripheral vision
uh
by itself well yeah because you the only
way you can get them to have
uh
vision towards the front is by putting
these things to the side so he won't get
scared or whatever
and the laser is the same thing and so
the question here is
that he phrased this question wrong okay
he's got an irrational question because
he
he's trying to uh put a scenario where
he puts maybe 10 atoms in a row and says
well how can you get the that beam to go
in one direction
okay why doesn't go in all direction
doesn't an atom pump
to every atom in the universe isn't it
uh radial
and so again uh the problem is with this
question with the way he phrases thought
experiment
and that's what he's got to work on and
until he can phrase it in a rational
manner i have nothing to answer i'll
answer the same way i did and that's
that do you know how many atoms are in
one centimeter
cube
of laser beam okay
and please answer that question first
you'll have gazillions of atoms there
and that'll give you a clue why why your
question is irrational okay so please
ponder that for a little while longer
that's all i can tell you right now
okay uh
here's uh
one fella says draw the hydrogen atom
for me and another one answer is
search atomic force microscopic hydrogen
you will get many articles images
sections uh will show pictures of
hydrogen bond
well the fellow didn't ask for a
hydrogen bond he asked for a hydrogen
atom
and i think the question was well taken
i mean please
uh tell me what a hydrogen atom looks
like draw it for me
and the other guy sidestep the question
he says look for a hydrogen bond there's
gazillions of pictures on it
okay let's uh let's look for him let's
let's please him okay
let's uh
see if we can
find what he's talking about you look
for this hydrogen bond and this is what
you find you find pictures
of atoms that they've done with atomic
force microscopes and different kinds of
microsoft powerful microscopes there
and these are the best pictures we've
got today
that's the first thing i want to mention
what do you see there well what you see
there is bubbles you see
some round things and we have to think
of them as three-dimensional meaning
we're talking about little globes little
bubbles
you know we're not talking about a flat
plain there this is not the flat earth
this is the 3d
spherical earth okay and so what you're
seeing there is a bunch of bubbles
okay
that's the first thing i want to mention
and that's the best shot we have and
this is not of hydrogen
okay what you're seeing here like in the
first case it's uh with boron and
nitrogen which are bigger atoms than
hydrogen
okay
so you're talking about a monster
atom compared to the hydrogen atom this
is a monster atom bigger
and that's the best picture we've got of
these
little monsters
it's a bird's eye view
okay and this guy's points to the
hydrogen bonds which is something a
little line that connects them
so what are we staring at
you know i mean
what does an atom look like forget about
the hydrogen bond what is the atom which
is much bigger
you can see it there it's a little
bigger than the little hydrogen bond
what is the what does the atom look like
any of those atoms
i'll give you nitrogen the biggest one
mentioned there so far okay
and so the question whether it looks
like this or like that here we have the
this and that
here's the quantum atom which it says
it's a little bead that's going around
uh
uh sun
it's a little planet around going around
the sun is that where you just observe
or did you observe a membrane a little
ball
like the one we propose in in under the
rope model did you see a little bead
going around here let me show you the
picture again okay here it is okay
do you see a bead going around moving
around is that what they took a picture
of a bead going around a center
is that what that is or are we staring
at a globe are we staring at a
membrane a little balloon
okay so that's uh the question before
this fellow so if he says uh look bill
uh it's uh looks like that
well okay uh so
is that what we stared at
okay are we staring at a little bead
going around i've never seen that i've
never seen the p orbitals going around
or the
or the you never see that what you see
is
you know balloons
that's what they can take a picture of
imagine if they took a picture
of a little bee going around we would
see a
nucleus of some kind and a bunch of
beads going around all these electron
beads that's what would show up right
but that's not what we see
and what we see is a surface
okay
that's all i can tell you you figure it
out on your own
go look for them don't don't rely on
testimony even mine okay so it says did
you know this one guy says did you know
that sometimes electrons do fall into
the nucleus
uh of an atom it is called electron
capture
okay don't tell me about falling into
the nucleus tell me why it doesn't
always fall doesn't spontaneously fall
or why it doesn't leave the orbits
the electron bead goes around and
typically it doesn't fall
into the nucleus there is no constant
electron capture because that would be
the end of the atom
right
no one of the issues that niels bohr
attacked was why didn't the electron
fall to the center of the nucleus of the
atom into the nucleus and his answer was
that you know the electron can only be
found in certain orbitals
and so the question is what keeps them
there what keeps them in those race
tracks why doesn't it
fly away spontaneously why does it fall
to the
center of the atom to the nucleus
spontaneously
so when you can answer that question
then you know then maybe we can talk
about it but right now you're saying
that there's an electron bead and
sometimes it falls to the center of the
atom
yeah i mean please draw your atom before
you do that okay i want to see your atom
okay
because it's easy to state
but unless you can draw and illustrate
your atom we don't know what you're
talking about
and we're suspecting the worst that you
you really don't have a a good atom one
that you can defend what you have is
the planetary model and you're talking
about the bead falling to the center of
the atom in what is called an electron
capture
yeah
easy to say hard to do
okay another foul g80 definition of life
independently travels against the path
of least resistance yeah okay
uh
well
independently there's a little more than
that it's a
natural object
natural object that travels against the
path of least resistance
and that's the definition of a living
entity the word is living or um
alive
so that defines alive and living and in
the set of living the set of alive
entities is what we call life okay so
that's the way it really works but uh he
kind of abbreviated there okay just
clarifying that point path of least
resistance undefined but the most
sensible i can invent
is direction of total push-pull
in other words in rational physics with
no spirits or intelligence literally
nothing can be alive by this definition
please redefine path of least resistance
to prevent all life from being struck
dead
okay
here's my answer okay here we have it
path of least resistance this is an
issue like shape for objects we don't
define shape and science because it is
understood by rational human beings the
definition of ordinary speech suffices
religious folk play devil's advocates
because rigorous definitions murder
their gods
okay
the reason this fellow raises this is
because uh you know something is is uh
missing in his mind he's saying uh why
don't you define path of least
resistance
we don't define every term in science
we don't have to define every single
term in fact uh by the way that is not
my official definition
okay for life that's the one i use on
the internet and the definition is in
the book you can find it there
it's the one that has a
fourth level
uh motion okay so you have to figure out
what fourth level motion is
uh anyways the point is that last
path of least resistance
is something that any individual
understands okay we don't have to go in
there's that what did you mean by that
what did you mean by that what did you
mean by the other thing you know that's
people who um
who
doubles advocates extreme devil's
advocates that uh are
uncomfortable with the definition
because it destroys their gods and of
course they have no definition to
propose an exchange okay so that's the
primary
issue there
fellow continues he says uh
phytoplankton coral larvae
dozens of species of bacteria and other
organisms that are simply carried along
water or air currents would be
considered not living under your
definition
he thinks that uh phytoplankton
are not alive that they have no motion
of their own
that's what he thinks my god what can i
say
yeah they're carried by the wind they're
carried by the water does that mean they
have no
proper motion of their own
well i'm not here to educate him that
much he should really take an
introductory course of biology in
science
you know in at the university uh
and he'll find out that yeah
phytoplankton and all these bacterias on
they do move
okay they move against gravity they also
are moved by the wind the fact that an
ant
you know i i i throw it in the air and
the wind carries the ant does that mean
an ant doesn't move
uh on its own
my god
anyways this is the
these are the types of questions some of
these people ask
okay uh here's another file and don't
bring natural oh i think it's the same
fellow don't bring natural artificial
into it because i'm saying it's got to
be an artificial and a natural object
champion one made by man okay
it's easy to rock uh two rockets are not
alive to say i guess rockets are not
alive despite going against gravity
because they are artificial yeah we
separate the artificial from the ones
mother nature made
because we want to make sure that we
consider the word living we restrict it
to those things that mother nature made
and not those that humans made and of
course he doesn't like it because it
destroys his argument well how about a
balloon how about an airplane in la la
la and when you say well it's going to
be a natural object ah but you you've
done away with half of my proposals yeah
that's the point of it the point of it
is that we usually use the word life in
terms of living entities meaning those
that mother nature created and so people
try to say well what about this and what
about that the devil's advocate again he
wants to introduce things that he may
especially like a computer program he
has bugs bunny movies it was bugs but
he's moving
is he alive there in in that picture
a two-dimensional bugs bunny
and again we chop all that off you know
pixels on a screen and so are they alive
uh we chop all that off by saying
natural object and of course
the devil's advocate gets upset at that
because it destroys his argument so he
says no don't include uh
don't reject artificial objects and so
he mentions the case here he says what
if you know we have uh we invent
we we create uh dna create a monkey in
the lab okay that's what he's saying so
he says the following says
uh it's easy to write okay he says
totally original dna engineered by nano
uh
biologists and made into an amoeba or
monkey or something would a monkey not
be alive just because some nut cooked up
his jeans in a lab
so you make a monkey in the lab you make
a champ or whatever in the lab
is that monkey considered to be alive
because it's secondary it's uh not made
by mother nature it was made by man
that's his question okay
and so this is the answer okay
here we go
uh the nanobiologist did not make the
monkey in the lab okay mother nature
made the monkey
nanobiologists merely toyed with
existing animals and molecules and jeans
and wombs and imitated mother nature's
design
okay
the fact that we uh copycatted uh mother
nature
doesn't mean that we created artificial
uh
things in motion in fact one of the
arguments that i use
against god is the is that one
uh you have the religious folk and they
say um
only a religion a uh a god an
intelligence a designer designed to
watch right you find a watch on the
beach you say well this could have been
done by
just coming to being
you know from the mountain you know from
the center of the earth someone made
that thing and if you see a watch on the
beach
like you go to another planet to see a
watch you say hey there's there's some
intelligence here that made that watch
okay
and so this is their argument the
watchmaker argument okay and so the
question here is if you create something
out there um
does that
make you
a god also you know you made a monkey
maybe you're making a monkey out of
yourself
the the issue here is the following okay
it's that uh humans have never been able
to create intelligence
okay they cannot create intelligence in
in the way mother nature created
intelligence okay
we try to imitate the brain and so we go
to the lab we bring we build these ais
okay artificial intelligences that we
call them and we say oh it's intelligent
well is it intelligent what do we mean
by intelligence then we have to define
that term in order to be able to talk
about it sensibly right and right now
i'm just going to give you the quick
verse i'm saying humans were never able
to create intelligence in other words we
cannot create the intelligence that
mother nature created like in our brains
or even in a in a brain like a lion you
know i mean lion has a certain
intelligence not not as good as ours uh
probably better than some of these guys
but not as good as normal human beings
but um
humans were not able to create
intelligence
okay we create a chip but we have not
created intelligence
and uh if we cannot
create intelligence
and we created watches but we have not
been able to create intelligence could
there be a designer out there that
created intelligence
you know uh like god
if if we cannot do it and god is
essentially us
you know and we created him in our image
did god create intelligence well we have
no proof that humans can create
intelligence so why do we think that
intelligence can create intelligence
and we have no evidence of your argument
okay so anyways the point here that i'm
trying to make is that um
we stand by the definition of life
and we're not going to include anything
men made by man okay anything made by
man is not living
it doesn't matter what you make even if
you make an android okay and you say oh
i made an android is that alive i don't
know uh we we reject it under the
definition of life because we want to
restrict
the definition of life to that which
mother nature made now
that's uh up to every single person if
you have a justification for saying that
an airplane is alive
because it moves against the path of
least resistance it moves against
gravity
well that's up to you you want to use it
if you have a purpose for using that
then use the word life
in that way
it's up to you as the presenter to you
to define the word life
any way you want that suits your your
theory okay
and if that's how you want to define it
fine but hopefully you find some use for
it it's not a question plains devil's
advocate and saying oh bill i'm going to
destroy your theory your your definition
because i'm going to include things
which are man-made
well my argument to that is again we
have no need for that in science
we want to restrict the word life to
that which
mother nature made and if you have a
different purpose for the word life that
suits your theory okay because that's
what it's about the definitions are part
of the hypothesis and are the
foundations of your theory then yes go
ahead and use the word life and include
all artificial objects that move against
gravity no problem
what use do you have for it in your
theory that's the bottom line
okay
final question
issue
father says
says asked on uh anton petrov he's a guy
who's got a runs a youtube site
more scientific proof that everything in
the universe is connected he's saying
that he
has been with that for like two years
now saying that things are connected
but the problem is that what do they
connect them with and where is he
getting his information he's getting his
information from relativists what are
relativists feeding him or what is he
you know siphoning from them
he's saying dark matter he's saying dark
energy that's what connects him
that's not a connection it's not a
physical connection he's insinuating
that the universe is connected meaning
physically connected and he doesn't
realize that these people are
introducing concepts
particles
supposedly you know
dark matter and dark energy are just a
bunch of particles that nobody can see
so how do you pull how do you connect
the entire universe which is the
explanation he gives how do you connect
the entire universe with particles with
discrete particles every particle is
isolated individually wrapped in space
so this particle is different than this
one and this one and this one and this
one how do you connect the universe with
discrete particles which is what
uh these people are suggesting the
universe of mathematical physics is a
particle universe it's a particle
hypothesis even the waves
the transverse waves are made of
particles
okay
so so
all of my mathematical physics is
founded on the on the basis of uh of
particles the particle hypothesis and so
you cannot talk about connection and
just say it and say oh yeah we have dark
matter and we have dark energy and that
interconnects us no you cannot connect
anything with little discrete particles
and so you know for him to talk for two
years and just bring the nonsense from
mathematical physics and say the
universe is connected
and what do you connect it with it we do
do it with uh dark matter and dark
energy what is he said
what is he talking about how can you
connect the universe with dark matter
first that we can't see we don't know
what it looks like please make it
visible make it so that we can see it
what is he going to put he's going to
put a bunch of particles in there
that weigh a lot because they're looking
for the particle of dark matter
in the
dark in the uh large hadron collider
they're trying to create the particle
called dark matter
okay so it is a particle that weighs
tons
that's what they're referring to
so if it's a particle how can you
connect two galaxies with dark matter
how do you do it or dark energy you want
dark energy go ahead use dark energy i
don't care
how do you collect connect all this
stuff with discrete particles
so using the word connect is misleading
and it's a lie that's not what they're
talking about they don't even realize it
they talk about connection but there is
no connection because
their world is what you see there
mathematical physics discrete particles
the rope model for the first time
introduces interconnectivity so if the
universe is connected it's got to be
like that
it can't be like the one on the left
okay
and so yeah uh so anton petrov can talk
all he wants uh he's not saying anything
that
mathematical physics hasn't been saying
and he doesn't even realize what he's
saying he's just regurgitating what
they're feeding him
okay
okay with that we'll see you not on
wednesday i've got a lot of work this
week i'm going to see you again next
sunday so please forgive me
and we'll see you then